who you are defines how you built
who knows what does entrepreneur is or
think they know all right we're gonna
talk a little bit about what is
entrepreneurs in today's discussion I
want to open up with a little bit of a
monologue here and let you know that
we're society and humanities at a really
interesting cusp or precipice but it's
clear that we're not on a path of
sustainability and we're gonna go in one
of either two directions either down the
path of this dr. Richard Leakey wrote in
his book the sixth extinction or we're
gonna completely reinvent every paradigm
and move the world in an entirely new
direction big paradigm shift so we're
talk about some really really big
concepts today I'm not gonna get too
deep we're gonna share a little bit
about quantum mechanics its impact on
human consciousness what that means to
entrepreneurship
what's intrapreneurship is all about so
it's gonna be a pretty exciting talk I'm
gonna try and condense things into sort
of a model and a framework that I hope
everyone can understand and follow me in
so let me expand a little bit more on my
career cuz I do you think it has a lot
of context for today's talk and I've
always considered myself a restless soul
how many restless souls do we have out
there yeah so always striving altruistic
wanting better better humanity better
myself striving for goals and this
career story I think matches what the
restless soul finds the centra preneur
so a little bit of background I started
out with a very Catholic heavy
upbringing and there was some really
good lessons that I learned there
probably the most principled one was
really all about a higher power and
caring about others having said that the
downside of that was I being a restless
spirit really rejected the dogma of
organized religion and the Catholic
faith in particular talked about this
concept of original sin and I also had a
really hard time thinking that if there
was a greater being who's probably
loving and compassionate
how could he have this concept of
original sin so that set me
into thinking about religion and
spirituality in a much broader context
and that sort of started me on that path
in seventh grade I had a teacher mrs.
Finnegan and I think what was happening
is I was probably falling into a little
bit of trouble and probably hanging
around with the wrong kinds of kids and
wanting to be cool and do what they did
and she pulled me aside and said have a
book for you it's called the
nonconformist and it was a really
interesting set point in my life which
said hey you don't have to follow
everyone else it's not about being cool
it's finding who you are who you're
meant to be and what your journey was
and it's interesting that at 57 years
old I haven't forgotten that book and
what that did for my life so that
entrepreneur lesson there I'm going to
talk a lot about this during my talk
today it's really all about creating
your own path it's easy to follow in
someone else's path society is heavily
heavily geared towards a what I call a
status quo struct set of structures that
benefit very few so the Machine of
capitalism the social issues that were
tackling all of that just trickles up to
the top 1% there's something like really
wrong with that structure right and if
you continue to follow down that path
you're just going to be a cog in that
large machine College is a period of
questioning everything most of you I
think I see a lot of young faces out
there in college it's a really amazing
time in your life a career those have
gone to college probably have very fond
memories of that experience in there so
without going into the decadent gory
details the lesson that I walked away
with that making compromises or
composing of this sort of zeal eva's
entrepreneur philosophy was this concept
of really thinking differently and
thinking about Who I am where I want to
go not just like I have to take this
computer science class I've got to hang
out with this people I wrestled in
college and really started to gain this
concept of becoming more conscious
consciously aware of thinking
differently and then started my career
at a technical track I moved into
product management the inside joke that
I say we're going to do the mediocre
programmers they make them product
managers so but the z lesson there was
really all about Steve Jobs talks about
this
it's a little bit of a cliche but it
really is all about finding your own
passion and lots of times you may not
know what it is today may not know what
is tomorrow but are you on that path are
you searching for that because once you
find that the world completely changes
for you and then had the opportunity to
do something really extraordinary I'd
never been an entrepreneur I was running
a billion-dollar software business and I
became very disenchanted with the
corporate strategy and then myself and a
kindred spirit left to start a company
and we had the vision to be the world's
largest web development company this was
back in 1995 I'd never run a
professional services company I never
been an entrepreneur I never raised the
penny and four years later we created a
company of 5000 employees operating in
17 countries around the world we were
serving half the fortune 500 doing the
most amazing state-of-the-art web
development work at that time we're
going through this entire transition
from an industrial revolution to a
digital economy and have a successful
IPO at the end of 1997 and it was
perhaps one of the most amazing learning
experiences of my time and what I
learned at that lesson was really more
about what not to do so what you find is
that the one thing that you can never
get back in your life is time so if you
smashed your car and get in your car if
you get a hole in your jeans you can get
new jeans or most people like the holey
jeans now today don't even have to do
that but most material things are all
replaceable in life time is not
replaceable in life and starting to
think that through no matter how much
work is done in human longevity this
body that you inherit right now today
has a beginning in the middle and an end
and the time that you have is incredibly
precious not to get into a morbid
conversation but the focus here should
be yeah my foot am I using my time
wisely am i spending on things that I
really enjoy am i growing as a human
being I am i contributing to society and
that started the framework of having a
million things to do with a startup got
to be really more focused on life with
like what's really important what what
shouldn't I be doing cuz you can't do
everything and you want to focus on
those things I was gonna make the
make the mark that you want on society
and create the kind of person that you
want to create attend change started an
incubator that was the vogue thing to do
at that time back in 1999 and it was
there where had some of my first pretty
big failures and and had the opportunity
to learn a really great lesson in
humility and what that was all about and
part of I think the challenge here in
Silicon Valley is that wealth does some
interesting things especially early on
in your life and when you never had that
and if I were honest with myself it
would be pretty self-absorbed I would
say really lacking in self-awareness and
also just really focused on being you
know fairly selfish and with a really
high ego oh my god I started this
company I've created all this wealth for
myself and it took that opportunity to
go and actually experience some failures
raise some money first startup have that
fail I have to sit down and tell your
employees that the company can no longer
be a growing concern having that call
with your investors that I'm sorry I'm
not gonna be able to return any of your
money and that was a really hard
self-reflection moment in my life and
was a seminal pivotal moment in my life
about the importance of humility and why
I should always carry that with you no
matter where you're at the ups and the
downs through life is having his humble
quality about yourself and then had the
opportunity to join a non-profit Board
of Directors in 2007 with the famous dr.
Richard Leakey and he's quite an
extraordinary individual discovered the
Lucy fossil and he wrote a book called
the six extinction and he really opened
up my eyes to climate change and
unfortunately everything that he's
predicted is coming true deforestation
dead zones in our ocean I mean the list
goes on I'm gonna talk more about that
but that was another seminal set point
in my life and really opened up my eyes
to we're really on an unsustainable path
right now and it really is it's
unconscionable to sit here and know what
problems that we're creating that we
don't even understand you know one order
of magnitude how large this is going to
be and leaving this for future
generations to come yeah that's a hard
pill to swallow
it really really is and the fact that
we're allowing the power structure of a
status quo society drive that agenda why
aren't we fixing that let's talk in the
mat is throughout Puerto Rico why is
that place still left up
it's crazy these are really easy
problems to solve let's see then I
decided to continuously stretch my
boundaries I was kind of retired for a
while
I never golfed I started out as a
terrible golfer being a type-a person I
started taking lessons ended up getting
three holes in one which was pretty cool
well I started surfing got to go to
Indonesia some very exotic surf places I
think I'm pretty good but against a pro
surfer Jarl sitting over here probably
not that good and it was an amazing time
and then being the person that likes to
be out front in the edge living as far
out in the edge as I possibly can
I decided 46 years old that Cagefighting
sounds like a cool thing I trained with
Frank Shamrock a four-time UFC world
champion did a number of cage fights and
he pulled me aside and said hey you know
seem like a bright guy you're 46 years
old there's really no career in here and
seems like you're doing a lot of this
just for vanity and when I stepped back
and thought about that I don't by the
way one of two things could probably
happen in here either you kind of mess
somebody up and you put them in a
hospital you get put in a hospital how's
that making any sense
and I said yeah you're right on that so
you can train it's it's incredible that
the metaphor is the meditation of
meditation and learning to train at MMA
so that was quite the lesson and what
the story of this is only one's read any
of Roman philosopher of philosophy
expert Seneca and then Osho wrote a book
on fear and when we get to that point in
life where when we transition that
transition becomes a lot easier if
you've lived your life with no regrets
and what I mean by that is that I've
made a ton of mistakes I'm gonna still
make mistakes I'm a human but I don't of
course I would do things differently if
I had the chance looking backwards you
don't have that ability as far as I know
no one's created a time machine where I
can go back in time but I really don't
have any regrets
everything I do in life I try and push
that on but the more you spend out in
front of your skis and the more you
stand pushing the boundary putting
yourself into really uncomfortable
situations where you the failure rates
really high or it's really difficult to
do the easy things to take the easy path
that's what creates richness in life and
that's what really resonated with me and
then finally on to executive position of
SolarCity tool they have another failed
startup in my resume Tesla and now
Autodesk and that's opening up an
entirely new chapter of what I want to
talk to you about today which is a
entrepreneur life so being a guy that
was a former engineer I loved charts
pretty easy like to create set of a
structure but the way I want to frame
this conversation today is to think
about your reality your world where
you're going in life on three dimensions
so one of those is this aspect called
consciousness it's what's going on in
your brain right now that no one knows
what that is that the x-axis is this
concept called wisdom wisdom is
comprised of knowledge that I gained and
they convert that into wisdom and then
the third dimension is how I take those
elements how I put that to action where
am I going in my life what kind of
person do I want to be what kind of mark
do I want to leave behind and sort of to
think those throughout at a really deep
philosophical level so what I'd like
everyone to do for a moment is please
close your eyes and take a big deep
breath in all the way feel it all into
your stomach let me hear and then let it
out just relax to stay here from with me
for a minute now I want you to go back
in time and I want you to think about
your one of your childhood places that
you lived and grew up but I want you to
picture the home see the staircase that
was there pictured the front door the
yard and I want you to open the door I
want you to walk into that home and see
the kitchen and the living room maybe
your mom and dad our brother or sister I
don't want you to walk down the hall in
your bedroom I want you to see what
color was on the
the bedspread that you remember maybe
had a desk in your room then once you
lay down in your bed now I want you to
open up your eyes my guess is that was a
really vivid memory in your brain that's
probably a long time ago no one knows
where those memories exist no one
science has perhaps the greatest mystery
of life is human consciousness where
those memories exist
there's no Dropbox there's no hard drive
on your brain where does that exist is
it really just between the ears is there
something bigger where does that exist
no one knows so let's talk a little bit
about that so I've been spending a lot
of time what I call the perfect trifecta
and now I'll make a confession I
absolutely hated philosophy in high
school hated it in college I also hated
physics it's too linear for me too much
math but recently I have been spending
an interesting amount of my time
learning about this exotic physics
called quantum mechanics which is really
below kind of the sub atomic level and
there's some really cool terms in here
and I won't try and lay out a deep
tactical conversation about this concept
of things that can be both particles and
wave at the same time so there's one
theory around what's called
superposition where a particle can be
actually two places at one time
the Schrodinger's cat there's another
concept called entangled particles where
these particles could be vast distances
apart and one is affected and it affects
something so far away
what are they connected by dark matter
dark energy and then another interesting
concept called the superstring theory
which is a definition to try and focus
on with the the aspect of particles and
waves and energy and how that all Co
exists in the universe and I wanted to
read something from a philosopher and
physicist that I've been a fan of info
on YouTube for quite some time John
Hagelin who's a world-renowned physicist
and leader the Transcendental Meditation
movement and he talks about that fourth
area there which is called the unified
field theory
so the unified field theory as the
Fountainhead of nature's intelligence an
ocean of pure existence and universal
intelligence it's dynamic its boiling
with energy he goes on to make a case of
how pure human consciousness is one in
the same with human consciousness taking
the outwardly directed mind typically
focused on the five senses turning that
attention powerfully from within to
experience deeper and deeper levels of
consciousness slipping beyond all that
thought and experiencing and just pure
being pure consciousness on abounded
awareness where the vibrational tones of
the unified field and pure consciousness
are one in the same these are really
crazy far-out exotic areas of study and
a study field my god does is your
consciousness connected to a unified
field it's fascinating and i taked out a
little bit step further I should I
should actually mention one more other
interesting experience so and then 80s
John is the head of David Lynch's
Transcendental Meditation organizations
about 44 million followers today and he
brought a several hundred of his
followers to Washington DC and it was a
murder capital of the world they had
insurance that Transcendental Meditation
session and then they actually measured
the level of murder after that and it
went down and stayed down permanently
after that he except another coalition
of several hundred others they went to
Lebanon in the 80s when there was brutal
violent civil war going on they had the
same session and they actually measured
a level of violence it had dropped and
it stayed it had been reduced
systemically over time so what this ties
into is that your brains got some really
interesting matter about a hundred mill
billion neurons and they are pulsing
with electrochemical activity and
manifests themselves in certain brain
waves so we'll start with sort of the
easiest one which is the beta waves and
their oscillating at X amount per second
and that's normally how you are in a
standard day you're in class studying
you're at work you're doing a lot of
things there's not a lot of time for you
to sort of think outside of like I've
got to write this paper I've got to
study for this test I've got this
assignment I have to do at work I've got
to recreate this marketing plan you're
typically running at what border called
beta ways not a lot of time to think
about new ideas not a lot of time to be
creative because your brains really
focused and cycling at that beta level
then there's alpha waves this is when
okay I've done a bunch of studying I
take a little bit of a break and then my
brain is to relax a little bit that the
frequency starts to slow down and get to
catch my breath a little bit and relax
that's an alpha state and then there's
stata waves and this happens when you
are in the state of a much more deeper
relaxed State
lots of times around meditation being
out with nature being focused being
present and that's where a lot of ideas
and creativity exists when you can get
your brain in that in that data state
sometimes you might feel you're driving
and you're all of a sudden five minutes
have gone by you don't even remember
driving but some ideas pop into your
head
that's the theta brainwave that that's
working you're in the shower or not just
relaxing feeling the water on your body
in a fader wait you some of the best
ideas happen when you're in the shower
right and then deltas typically when you
are completely deep asleep you're not
dreaming on average dreams happen about
90-minute cycles called REM sleep but
then the Delta it's they can't get have
any brain activity because we'd be dead
but you're in a very very deep sleep now
the more interesting brainwave activity
really comes from this gamma state and
when you're able to get into this deeper
state of meditation or deeper
consciousness is when the truth is magic
begins to occur
we're actually super relaxed but your
brain is operating at this gamma level
exploding with energy exploding with new
ideas and where the most interesting
things begin to happen so I wanted to
give you a little bit of a project on
why this whole consciousness dimensions
so important and how it's going to play
in Zen shape in your life
so I opened up my talk today telling you
that there's a fork in the road and the
term I like to use it's a Greek word
called Kairos which means a unique
moment in time we're at that moment
right now so path a is what I call the
zombie path right and this is where we
just continue to do what we're doing to
do with the planet with our Conant
economic structure and if you start to
think about that there was actually a
famous neuroscientist that spoke here at
Stanford many years ago David Eagleman
and he cited this research that was done
that when you're 2 or 3 years old is
when your brain is the most creative and
the most active the most neuroplasticity
and because of Darwin principles when
you don't use it it begins to atrophy
and in a hundred percent of the cases by
the time 50 years later when you're 52
or 53 you have half the neuroplasticity
that you had when you were two or three
years old and you might hear Jeff Bezos
talk about when he tries to get into
creative mode he puts himself in this
six year old kind of mindset and trying
to really focus on how do I get back all
this magic creativity that I once had
when in my youth and if any of you spent
any time around young children they have
no boundaries Matt's got a
seven-year-old my guess is that his
ideas are probably so out of this world
and so creative because they haven't
been forced into this structure this
zombie structure we do the same thing
day in and day out you meet with the
same people day in and day out you do
the same things day in and day out and
that electromagnetic electrochemical
network just keeps getting deeper and
deeper and deeper the grooves just kept
key deeper and deeper and what's the end
result of that we've got some of the
most hugest economic the income
diversity problems that we haven't seen
since the Great Depression and it's hard
for me to sit here and look at the
status quo path and go everything's
gonna be alright because I don't believe
that everything is gonna be alright if
we stay on that that current course and
speed
so we've got massive what I call we need
we need a modern set of new paradigm
shifts across the entire board from a
planetary sustainability standpoint
economy social ethics laws government
and I want to talk a little about where
you're spending your time and how I
think you should be spending your time
so I've got a few more stats for you
let's talk about the planet an area near
and dear to my heart so I spent a bunch
of time at solar city and a Tesla
deforestation we've lost 46 percent of
our trees and nearly 100,000 acres are
cut down every single day our waters
each year one point true two trillion
gallons of untreated sewage stormwater
and industrial wastes are dumped into
our US waters the great Garbage Patch in
the Pacific Ocean it's twice the size of
Texas at an atmospheric level we have
over four hundred and five parts per
million of co2 in our atmosphere
now I remember back in the 90s we talked
about there's going to be massive havoc
if we actually get over 400 parts per
million
we're now at 405 and the most stunning
figure and what dr. Richard Leakey
really talked about was biodiversity and
how many plants and animals are being
extinct is that an epic level humans
have destroyed 83% of all mammals and
half the plants since the dawn of
civilization it would take five to seven
million years for the natural world to
recover a million species now face
extinction within decades our rate of
destruction tens to hundreds of times
higher than the average over the past
ten million years ten million years
how's that sustainable population growth
continues to expand globalization
continues at an epic rate our
biodiversity is being reduced at
alarming rates and the power structure
of what I call the zombie or the status
quo continues to chug along Wall Street
if you have
investments in stocks I guarantee you
the billionaires are out way before any
kind of market crash who ends up picking
up the tab on that you do mainstream
America does economy we have a massive
income inequality problem here so you
can look going back to 1963 and now fast
forward into 2016 and you can see a
pretty
disparate chart here and as I said
earlier in my talk this disparity hasn't
existed since the Great Depression and
I'm not here touting socialism I
actually don't believe in any of those
labels I don't believe in conservatism I
don't believe in liberalism loving you
and being me and being human beings and
focusing on how we changed the world
together and tackle things without being
divided and labeled this or that because
I do think that there are some aspects
of what we have that are good and great
and can move forward in the 21st century
and certainly a lot of challenges that
we have that need to be addressed and I
had one other stat which was consumer
debt has risen to four trillion dollars
from a mere couple hundred billion just
fifty years ago so in addition to this
the problems exacerbated because now
we've got massive consumer debt some of
the social issues that we have in front
of us are rapid population growth
maybe we'll top out maybe I think 2050
10 billion is the current prediction
we'll see if that happens
growing inequality a real problem with
aging population rising healthcare costs
global and religious conflicts poverty
that still exists today which just seems
crazy a 21st century with the wealth
that society has created that people are
dying because they can't have clean
drinking water and can't have a roof
over their head and can't get a basic
meal every day and certainly at the
energy level the fact that we still
drill baby drill it it's nothing short
of disgusting
when these people that are working in a
coal mine could literally go and work
and putting solar up there's so many new
alternatives so much more innovation
that we could solve these problems
ethics laws in government is there an
ethical company out there look what
these companies do with your data
they're just focused on a couple things
growth ok how they get there Wall Street
pushes them to grow and they're focused
on their balance sheet all right what's
my balance you look at what my income
statement look like in my metrics versus
what are you doing to society how do we
tackle some of the
is that we have criminal justice reform
huge area gerrymandering the fact that
undercuts and undermines our democratic
systems and I went outside does the
government work just yesterday or the
other day president Trump's former chief
of staff John Kelly has taken a board
position for a venture capital firm in
Washington DC that is heading up the
largest child migration Center is that a
good use of capital these are our
leaders and lastly the most important
resource that you have that I talked
about at the beginning this presentation
that's your time that's all you have at
the end of the day where are you
spending it well the zombie people are
spending it well most people a third of
it is sleeping on average 47 hours a
week so sleeping and working that's all
that's basically two thirds of your life
are gone right there so that means that
the time you're not sleeping or working
should be really focused on activities
and things that make that you're
passionate about excited about things
that you can do to really change the
world the kind of mark that you want to
leave on society we spend 24 hours a
week online Instagram snapchat five
hours they consuming media good Lord
like I don't what's happened to
journalism today and the garbage you get
from from all of the the 24/7 cable news
networks what's left of your time so
where am I going with all of this
a what I'll call is the beginning of a
conversation around some of these
amazing challenges that we have and how
to overcome them and I will say that
aside from painting probably a really
bleak depressing picture I've never been
more optimistic in my life than I am
today and having had a chance now I'm at
my ninth year teaching here at Stanford
and thus entrepreneur life philosophy a
lot of it was born here at Stanford
University because when I get to
interact with the most amazing students
in the world it's a window into the
future how you think about the world the
kind of people
that you want to become the things that
are important to you where you want to
focus your time and energy and I will be
so bold as to say that is the most
advanced human consciousness generation
of all time of all history and where
this really rang true for me was during
the horrific parkland land shooting and
to literally see 16 a 17 year old high
school kids go on CNN and be so
articulate about gun issue I'm like any
politician who's sitting in their office
gerrymandering and where did that come
from
where did your intellect come from I
have to think that the internet its pros
and cons have a lot to do with bringing
incredible knowledge to you incredible
insights to you maybe some of the
upbringing that you've had but you're
thinking about the world like no other
generation it's incredibly refreshing to
see and it gives me extraordinary hope
that this this movement this opportunity
that we have is going to be
extraordinary perhaps the greatest
creative movement in the history of
humanity that's how excited I am and how
optimistic I'm I am on the future and a
challenge that I have together is that
how do we literally reinvent every
paradigm instead of sitting back and
allowing a structuring system to benefit
phew we just have to reverse the pyramid
not that hard as a bunch of smart people
in this room but it's a great
opportunity that how do we basically
completely reinvent the paradigm across
the board how do we shift our thinking
right and I'm gonna introduce this
concept called Zen ship in your life set
of principles that again begin that
conversation and as I said earlier if I
could leave you with one message it's
this concept of living with absolutely
no regrets not saying be completely
reckless your parents probably wouldn't
be too happy about that but do things
you've never done meet people you've
never met travel when you can create
much broader open networks the world is
literally yours you have infinite power
you have infinite creativity you're just
not using it and would invite you to
join
with me so instead of reading off the 21
principles which as I said has largely
been generated through the Stanford
student body that I've had the
opportunity interact with it also is a
reflection of looking at how some of the
brightest entrepreneurs of all time have
led their companies what goes on in
their consciousness
so it's this blend and then the third
leg to the stool would be your your
brand of spirituality mine happens to be
around Zen Buddhism I believe in that
but I've got deep Christian background I
think all religious have a lot to offer
but there is this part of spirituality
element that also is blended into this
concept so let me have the video tell
the story earth home for decades
mankind has achieved wonders on this
planet we've terraformed the land built
cities in the desert and islands out of
sand yet at the same time our forests
are burning glaciers melting and lakes
drying up
our lives have been threatened by our
very own creation but we are the next
generation we can change our trajectory
and course-correct what's been done by
past generations to create a better
future
[Music]
centra preneur life is a philosophy to
spark change it offers a roadmap to
tapping into your infinite creative
power through the following 21
principles believe in something greater
than yourself lived in gratitude a
strive to make the world a better place
believe in infinite possibilities be
transparent be kind
give more
lead by example be bright share
positivity have faith that you will
succeed no matter the circumstances
be present continually strive for
personal growth spend time in nature
listen live in pursuit of perfecting
your craft have a dedication to defining
your own path build open networks make
your own opportunities fuel your mind
body and spirit with healthy nutrients
know the real prize is the journey don't
take life too seriously
laughs sing and dance more be willing to
explore your edges we choose to go to
the moon not because they are easy but
because they are hard
yesterday we terraform the land built
cities in the desert and islands out of
sand
tomorrow well we have a better plan
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so I don't have all the answers
there are people on this planet way way
smarter than me what I do want to do
though is begin a conversation I want to
find some kindred spirits I want to find
some difference makers that want to
completely reinvent our planet
completely reinvent these broken
paradigms that we have it's a huge
audacious goal and as morbid as the
picture might sound weather where there
are big challenges that's where big
opportunities exist and it's an amazing
time to be alive right now it's an
amazing time to be who you are where
you're at in this lifetime and you truly
have the power to really do anything
that you set your mind to and a matter
of fact one of those principles about
infinite possibilities and seeing no
boundaries it reminds me of the times
when I had the opportunity to be in a
meeting with Elon Musk and there were
virtually no boundaries in his thinking
none whatsoever
who would have thought that you could
have built the company that would go and
completely reinvent the automotive
industry and build a company that could
completely reinvent the energy paradigm
that's all possible and that's just the
start that's just the tip of the iceberg
I guarantee you there's hundreds of
millions of Elon Musk's out there
probably several sitting in this room
right here today just see the courage
and the conviction to stay take that
step forward and ultimately as I said
earlier we're mortal and all you have
left and when you leave this planet and
this human body is what you've done you
don't leave with your car you don't
leave with your house you don't leave
with the clothes on your back that would
challenge you all to think about what
kind of indelible mark do you want to
leave at this moment in time so the
zombie path I call that the path of many
that's the easy path that's the path
that everyone goes on I would challenge
you all the three things
imagine what others can you all have
power there's not one person in this
room that doesn't have infinite creative
power and capability you just have to
put yourself on the right path and
believe you can do it and find search
for these amazing opportunities that
exist out there that will enlighten your
world that will bring a whole new level
of consciousness to your being and where
you are and where you're going your
disposition on life and what your
version of reality is secondly do what
others won't take on the hard things
that's where the that's where the magic
of life is that's where the spirit of
life is it's easy to take the easy job
it's easy to be lazy the hard difficult
challenge to do the other things that
others don't
and lastly lead like others others don't
and what an amazing institution here and
a group of people that have this
incredible intellect and this
opportunity in life that virtually
anyone and everyone that wants to be a
leader can truly be a leader going
forward so let me finish up since I'm
going to come back to a little bit of my
program or mine here or the fancy little
chart and hopefully my talk today give
you a little bit more context for what
these dimensions are all about and I
would challenge you all to expand your
human consciousness there's infinite
ways that you can do that I might start
with meditation might start with meeting
new people think about that brainwave
chart that I showed and how to get more
out of the beta mode which nothing good
happens there other than health issues
and problems when you're stressed out
worried about this or worried about that
that's just the reality that you're
creating for yourself and we all have
challenges in life absolutely do some
are some are more challenging than
others but you can choose to let that
dominate your life you can choose to let
that impact your reality or you can
shift your mind to a different an
entirely different mode and I would
coach you all into really moving forward
expand your human consciousness because
that's where all the magic that's where
all that creativity lies right secondly
but also encourage you
to increase your knowledge and wisdom
how do you do that well how he's
spending your time right action
are you meeting new people what new
things are you doing every day every
week or every month could be simple
things like playing guitar taking up an
art and craft making some jewelry -
thinking about some of the bigger
problems and challenges that we have in
life but really focus on versus snapchat
social media LinkedIn same thing day in
and day out you're just in a groove
you're going nowhere in life think
bigger think broader because there are
no boundaries the only boundaries you'd
have or what or what you are physically
imposing on yourself it's all mine said
at the end of the day so I want you all
to expand in the wisdom category and
lastly as you think about those two
dimensions where are you going to spend
your actions it's almost like
body-mind-spirit
are you gonna be going through the same
motions get some trips that are planned
some new people that you can meet some
new people that you can have coffee with
because again the only restrictions only
boundaries are the ones that that you've
all placed on yourself there are none
I'd love for you to think about some of
the concepts I lay it out today so I'm a
little bit technical in the air of
quantum mechanics but the point that I
was really trying to make was actually a
really interesting link happening now
between science and human consciousness
and spirituality where it exists where
it's all going this infinite power that
you can tap into and what's amazing is
that I'll bet you don't know the Milky
Way galaxy today is traveling at over 1
million miles an hour through the
universe and we're sitting here right
here at Stanford University just think
about the concept of that for a moment
so this one aspires me future
generations to come that's what drives
me to do the things that I do to be so
gifted has an incredible opportunity
here to teach at Stanford University to
give back to give more than you take and
I do care about future generations to
come it does bother me that I could be
doing more to solve some challenge
maintain biodiversity some of the
planetary issues that we have social
issues that we have and I think everyone
has it has an ethical and moral
responsibility to create a planet leave
a planet that's better than what you
inherited and as I said today I could
never be more excited I believe that the
opportunity is nothing like I've ever
seen in my lifetime and the future is
completely yours the possibilities are
absolutely infinite how do we know what
we're gonna do without creating new
problems well here's what I'm going to
tell you you are absolutely gonna create
some new problems with what you do no
matter what but what I would tell you is
that the the slight problems if you're
pure of heart and focused on doing the
right thing that will end up correcting
itself and what I mean by that is so let
me give you an example I watched this
movie about to eat the Eagles
documentary and when Glenn Frey was
living upstairs at Jackson Browne and
when Jackson Browne started to write
write a song he literally would practice
the same verse over and over again it
was driving Glenn Frey crazy he didn't
know how to write music and he kept
practicing and practicing and playing
and the first iterations of it were
absolutely terrible created a lot of
mistakes over time it got better and
better and that's what he said to
himself
ah it's elbow grease it's working really
hard so I would rather you know in
business right what's the worst thing
you can do it's not make a decision at
all the most important even if it's
wrong that's like you take them you get
the best data that you can you think
things through the problem that you're
trying to solve and at that point like
everyone's going to make mistakes and
you'll probably end up creating some
collateral damage along the way but what
you end up doing and solving ism is
gonna pale in comparison to potentially
some of the collateral damage that
you've caused so that's my philosophy on
that any other questions yes
incentive structures or what kpi's to
build on that don't perpetuate the same
paradigms
yeah Wow a different set of structure
for different KPIs on building
businesses that I assume are more
ethically moral god that's a really
great question so I'm sitting here in
Silicon Valley and without completely
pissing off the entire venture capital
community but I think that you know
we'll have roughly a hundred and eighty
billion dollars going into venture
capital new innovation that and it
literally occupied by several hundred
venture capitals that model is
completely wrong and broken so because
they're there literally for one reason I
don't blame them for that but they have
limited partners they raise that money
and then they have to deliver really
great returns on that and I have lots of
ideas and what I think a new model would
look like and again it all has to start
with sort of flipping the paradigm so if
we continue to work through the same
structure you're gonna get the same
behavior which is like grow grow grow
grow grow burn your people I'll burn
your people out your disposable I need
growth I need my balance sheet to look
this way these KPI so I think B
corporations is a really good start in
that direction about having a set of
looking at your supply chain is it
ethically source where the material is
coming from is the no slave labor coming
with that I have a bunch of other you
know but that to me is in the in the
right direction and I think it is all
about sort of a conscious awakening and
then how do we reinvent the traditional
venture capital I think it's hard to try
and superimpose what we need to do on
that I think it's all about creating a
new paradigm yeah stations ordinary so I
I've been surfing too much I got a bunch
of water mayor Matt yep yeah that's a
great question I actually talked to my
class about that concept so if you'd
asked me nine years ago hey a professor
Cory give me some tips on my career I
would've given you a boilerplate answer
go go work for a large company that's
the market leader in their category go
learn and then feel and
creating a really good idea have some
unique insight then that's the right
time to go do your own thing actually
think it's the exact opposite of that
but what I would say is that there isn't
a one-size-fits-all so where I've gotten
is that I would absolutely do things
differently I would not go through the
traditional route that I went through
think that was sort of me being
conservative me being just sort of
focused on my career okay what's the
next promotion for me what's the next
raise for me and being methodical and
being a zombie and just following
quarter that that tried-and-true path so
what I would say that I'm not saying
being an entrepreneur is for everybody
but I do think that there are massive
opportunities to get involved in in many
different ways
versus and if you know what at the end
of a if that is what you're feeling
right now of the traditional path that's
awesome I don't regret that at all
what you should do what I would
encourage you also make sure like are
you getting all the data into think
about that decision that's the right way
to think about that problem is like
because at the end of the day you have
the sixth sense that exists inside you
right and you have this somatic
intelligence system you're not telling
yourself to breathe you're not telling
your heart to be there's an natural
intelligence that is inside your body
and there's this thing called a gut a
gut feeling something that's in your
heart something that you feel right and
that's part of consciousness doesn't
exist anywhere you all have that
capability you know when something's
right for you and I would just encourage
you to like don't doubt that go with
your heart even if it turns out where
yeah maybe not the right thing I'm kind
of facing a similar situation right now
I'm at peace with my decision to where
I'm going on that and I just don't have
any regrets I want to put myself out
there more so what I would say is like
learn from what I did and stand on my
shoulders and think about a broader
opportunity for yourself make sense all
right one more question
Joe would you go into one of the tenants
was about building open networks yeah
give us a tip son yeah so okay open
networks again thinking about that
paradigm that I talked about where we do
the same things day in and out so what
does current structures drive towards so
LinkedIn it's set up that you really
just connect with people that you
already know you
work with and I know myself like
whenever I've reached out sometimes if
you reach out to connect with people
that don't know you if if you get too
many nose I don't know that person
LinkedIn will actually warn you and then
after if you keep doing it it will it
will lock you out of your account for a
certain period of time what does social
media set up oh you hang around with
these types of people you have these
types of political views you buy these
types of products you're in the same
swim lane Twitter all of that stuff so
what we're creativity comes from is
having more expansive data points so if
you're literally in the same swim lane
and have the same people with the same
views you're not going to expand so the
concept of an open network which is an
area that I'm thinking about how to how
to drive more mentorship into the world
especially for young people because I
think that's one of the ingredients in
one of the opportunities that we have
and that's almost like what would be
like if you had your own personal board
of directors that could help you think
about your life and it could be a domain
that your should robotics AI whatever
that might be but other individuals that
you never would have thought of
connecting with and can bring an
entirely new perspective from anywhere
around the globe and what we found
there's actually there was a study done
that a Forbes magazine article I can get
it for you but scientific data actually
shows that the more open networks that
you have none of the more successful you
are in life but the happier our life the
more fulfilled that you feel in life so
the concept that open network is that
we've got to step outside of this these
current structures and systems that that
literally punky punky you in the same
swimlane you gotta get to a whole bunch
of swim lanes
you
[Music]